you look fantastic you look fantastic
and i don't think i'm giving away
any secrets you you just had a birthday
you in december you turned
66. this
this is how i want to look when i'm 66 i
would kill to look the way you look
right now you'll look better you have
more hair
everything's going your way no no no no
i'm got that irish face that just i'm
like a pumpkin that rots in the sun
it's all it's i'm going to look awful
it's going to look
terrible uh but there are all these
articles now
that are talking about you calling you
the silver fox
and there's i saw an article today
i'm serious i saw an article today
that's that listed you as one of the top
older men we'd like to go to bed with
and i i've got to imagine this is
first off every one of my kids just went
right yeah but i think if you read the
article more carefully it's
the person you most want to take a nap
with
he doesn't seem like he hogs the covers
yeah
there's a certain age when you don't
want to you know you don't want to hear
people talking about you know
right that yes thing yeah yeah trust me
i hit that age when i was 25.
uh still the whole thing horrifies me uh
you know your your lovely wife mary
steenburgen said and this is a quote i
used to think ted was superficial and
slick
but slick guys don't say gasharooni
after making love
did you really say gosharoon i have and
if you ever
have the opportunity to make love to my
wife you'll say gosh rooney
i'll say gashirooni my wife is going to
kill me
uh well you seem like where'd you get
like gasharooni it almost feels like
you're from
the old mayberry show you know like you
almost feel like you have kind of a
an old-timey way of speaking i you know
i i noticed that i i
i'm starting to pick up phrases that my
parents said
jokingly as they got older but they were
referencing the turn of the century
right so all of a sudden i'm like i'm in
the early 1900s
saying things that they used to say
because it makes me feel good
remembering them and
same thing they say so it's a it's yeah
it's accessory slope
rooney would be something that you
picked up as a kid and now it's coming
into your everyday
oh that would be swell that would be a
swell
it's a good one yeah yes that's the
bee's knees bee's knees i say it all the
time know
don't applaud like you know what i'm
talking about
there's an eighteen-year-old over there
going bee's knees
this this is uh how old how about your
audience basically because we're
trending
plus right now i mean on your show
research has shown that we do very well
with 11 year olds
yeah that's yeah that's where
most most the people in our crowd right
now
are just learning to use the bathroom